[music]
we are looking forward to working with the
european commission everyone
in the federal government is motivated
i can really
send this message to brussels with absolute certainty and that
there is a lot to do
that also became clear in our
conversation today thank you very much for us
we had this conversation knowing that
europe can count itself lucky that in
this critical phase we
can count on a presidency that has
such a wealth of european
experience the german
presidency of the council and the european commission can indeed make a
significant contribution together to ensure that europe
not only together  and dust is navigating through
this crisis, but the next
generation view is also becoming an
accelerator of modernization
within europe